KNOWS MAYBE SHERMAN STILL
DOES COME BACK TO SEATTLE
WHICH WOULD MAKE FOR SOME
LOOK, YOU KNOW THE ONE THING
THAT'S LOST IN THIS IS THAT
RICHARD SHERMAN WOULD MAKE
THE SEAHAWKS BETTER IN 2021.
YOU'RE NOT SIGNING RICHARD
SHERMAN. NOBODY'S GOING TO
SIGN HIM FOR THREE OR FOUR
YEARS UNLESS THEY'RE VOIDABLE
YEARS, YOU KNOW ON THE BOTTOM
OF THE CONTRACT SO, YOU KNOW
AS I LOOK AT THIS WITH THE
RICHARD SHERMAN THING, I SEE
IT MORE IN AN
IN A MORE INNOCENT WAY. I
EFFECTIVE IT COULD BE THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT MIKE, BUT I SEE
IT IN A WAY. LIKE HEY, LISTEN,
WE JUST LOST GRIFFIN EVEN
THOUGH HE'S NOT A GREAT
QUARTERBACK, BUT HE SIGNED
WITH JACKSONVILLE. WE ARE
RANKS AT THE CORNER POSITION
RIGHT NOW ARE NOT GOOD AND TO
GET RICHARD SHERMAN, EVEN IF
HE ONLY MAKES IT THROUGH SIX
OR EIGHT GAMES THAT WOULD
IMPROVE US SIGNIFICANTLY ON
THE OUTSIDE. WOULDN'T YOU BE
BETTER OFF THOUGH WAITING TO
SEE WHAT YOU GET IN THE DRAFT.
MAYBE YOU GET A YOUNGER GUY.
IT'S GOT FULL TREAD ON THE
TIRES WHO COMES IN AND MAYBE
DEVELOPS INTO SOMEONE WHO
WOULD BE AS GOOD AS WE'RE
SHERMAN IS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
HE'S CLEARLY ON THE DECLINE
PETER. THE QUESTION IS HOW
MUCH IS LEFT IN THE TANK.
YEAH, BUT MIKE WHEN YOU'RE
THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS AND YOU
HAVE THREE DRAFT CHOICES AND
YOUR FIRST ONE ISN'T UNTIL
THE 50S
TO THINK YOU CAN COUNT ON A
GUY WHO'S DRAFTED EITHER ON
THE SECOND OR THIRD DAY OF
THIS DRAFT AND TO THINK THAT
THAT GUY CAN STEP IN AND TO
GIVE YOU ANYTHING IN
SEPTEMBER LIKE WHAT RICHARD
SHERMAN COULD IS JUST NOT
SO THAT'S THE ONLY REASON I
MEAN AND LOOK I HAVE NO IDEA
IF THEY COULD EITHER AFFORD
HIM OR IF THEY COULD WORK OUT
ONE OF THESE CONTRACTS WHERE
THEY WOULD YOU KNOW DO FOR
FAKE EARS ON THE END OF A
ONE-YEAR DEAL. THAT'S
PROBABLY THE WAY THEY'D HAVE
TO DO IT. BUT THE ONLY WAY
THAT THEY COULD YOU KNOW THAT
THEY WOULD REALIZE THIS OR THE
ONLY WAY I THINK THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING WITH A
YOUNG QUARTERBACK IS TO TRADE
DON'T SEE THAT THAT JOHN
SCHNEIDER HAS EITHER THE
AMMUNITION OR ANYTHING. I
THERE HAS BEEN NOT
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN
SHERMAN SINCE HE BECAME A
FREE AGENT THE SAINTS AT ONE
POINT WHERE MENTIONED I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT EVER WENT
ANYWHERE JON GRUDEN OPENLY
TAMPERED WITH SHERMAN BACK
BEFORE FREE AGENCY STARTED
THE RAIDERS HAVE EMERGED. DO
YOU ATTACH ANY SIGNIFICANCE
PETER TO THE FACT THAT
SALAH THE DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR IN SAN FRANCISCO
DURING THE ENTIRETY OF
SHERMAN'S TIME. THERE IS THE
HEAD COACH OF THE JETS AND IS
NOT MADE A BEELINE TO TRY TO
BRING SHERMAN IN TO TEACH THE
SYSTEM THE YOUNGER PLAYERS
AND GIVE HIM A VETERAN
PRESENCE IN THE LOCKER ROOM
AND JUST BASICALLY BE EYES
AND EARS AND AND MOUTHPIECE
FOR WHAT'S ALL IS TRYING TO
DO.
NO QUESTION. I DO APPLY AN
UPRAISED EYEBROW TO THAT AND
LOOK THE WAY THE JETS WORK
ROBERTS ALLAH'S GOING TO HAVE
TO CONVINCE JOE DOUGLAS IF HE
WANTS SOMEBODY TO COME IN
BECAUSE JOE DOUGLAS HAS GOT
FINAL PERSONNEL SAY, YOU KNOW,
IT'S SORT OF LIKE IN A WEIRD
WAY THE WAY JOHN SCHNEIDER
HAD TO CONVINCE PETE CARROLL
IN 2012 ABOUT RUSSELL WILSON
BECAUSE PETE CARROLL HAD
FINAL PERSONNEL SAY, YOU KNOW
IN THE DRAFT THAT YEAR SO
YOU KNOW TO ME I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE ROBERTS ALLAH HAD X
NUMBERS ABOUT X NUMBER OF
BATTLES THAT HE COULD FIGHT
AND I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
HE WANTED TO GO TO THE WALL
FOR RICHARD SHERMAN BECAUSE
FOR WHATEVER REASON AND LOOK
HE LOVES RICHARD SHERMAN AND
RICHARD SHERMAN LOVES HIM.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW THE STORY
BEHIND IT. MAYBE SHERMAN SAID
LOOK, I'M NOT COMING EAST.
I'M NOT LEAVING MY FAMILY
BACK HERE. I'M NOT MOVING
BACK THERE. IT'S A PANDEMIC
BLAH BLAH BLAH. I DON'T KNOW
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT'S
CURIOUS TO ME THAT THAT SOLID
DIDN'T GO HARD AFTER RICHARD
SHERMAN. ALL RIGHT, WE'VE